and so i will give you a second part of
this lectures jennifer will give the
last part on friday
um
so
just i will give you a quick review so
let me run through that so we are
interested in
when do should we consider two large
graphs to be similar what's the correct
notion of a limit
and how do we model
non-parametric models i address this
question at length
so here is the summary
in the most general setting we can have
some probability space think of it as a
feature space in any dimension you put
some probability measure over it and you
have a graph
and then you choose your features iid at
random
and then you connect the graph and then
says it's the probability of connecting
if you have teacher x i and i have
feature xj
okay
and alice hoover said that this is a
pretty natural model in particular any
family of random graphs gn which come
from some infinite graph and which is
exchangeable gives this
okay so that is
for dense graphs this is sort of
z natural class of models
then i introduced some notions of
similarity
one of them was just counting subgraphs
so this is essentially counting induced
subgraphs
so if these were distinct
then you would just look at k different
vertices in your large graph
then you look whether an edge is there
if it's in the graph h and you look that
it's not there if it's not in there so
this would the indicator function that
it's an induced subgraph and you can't
and
it's convenient for me to allow these to
have conflicts and i divide by one over
volume to the k
and the two would be the same as n goes
to infinity anyhow
okay
and then we define sampling very similar
we choose x1 up to xk uniformly at
random and we output the sampled
subgraph
and
they're actually similar in a very
precise way
you can just look what is the
probability of seeing a particular graph
well it's a number of times you see it
divided by the number of maps which is
just that
okay
so as a consequence
if you want to know whether these
distributions are similar or these
numbers are similar there's a very
simple one-to-one correspondence the
total variation distance between the two
distributions
is i'm using a slight abuse of notation
to write the total of the random i mean
i mean the total variation distance of
these two variables
is nothing but one half the l1 distance
okay
so the two of them are equivalent so at
least two of these notions are
equivalent
i introduced two other ones generalized
main cuts
where you had
weighted cuts weighted by some matrix j
and alpha fixed the size of the classes
so this generalizes min by section
where j would just be
would be sort of
the
off diagonal one and alpha would be one
half and they are sort of all other
kinds you can get densest sub graph and
all kinds of things are in here and
these are generalizations of that and
the physicists were interested in the
free energy they were also defined in
terms of this cuts
but you weighted things by e2's minus
beta some took the log and you got your
free energy we i will not discuss these
much more this time except that i will
state
states
but i won't state the main theorem yet
because i also introduced silver view
the cut metric so what do we do for that
we take our graph
we create
a checkbot
and then we put a black dot wherever
there is an edge
and
a one and otherwise a zero and here i
have drawn once as black and zeros as
white maybe you want to do it the other
way around i don't know how your
computer signs in code ones and zeros
but on the screen but
for i've done it like that
and
so now
we defined a cut norm
so in the example where this w would
just be some step function like that
okay
here i've drawn an example where s would
correspond to a set of vertices t
corresponds to a set of vertices maybe
this this and this and t
is another set and in this picture
this is s this is t
and then the red edges are the edges in
the graph which go from s to t so it's a
cut between s and t in the graph and so
this would be the cut in the graph
and you do the maximum so in other words
if you compared two objects you have a
picture like that and a picture like
that on 50 vertices it will look sort of
similar like that and you will compare
the cuts in these two graphs and they
will be very similar and therefore they
will be considered near in this norm
okay
but if i start to scram if i relabel the
vertices and put the all the odd
vertices first and then all the even
vertices you would start to get a
picture with lots of white and black
mixed around
and if you subtract this one from it you
would get something which is very near
to one half or one third or whatever you
get there and it will never go to zero
okay so that's so this one doesn't have
invariance by permutations
which we'll have to fix but before
fixing that
let me note that equivalently you can
write this like this
and the reason is
well
let me do the sort of fancy answer this
is a linear function in f and linear
function in g
on sort of this compact domain and it
and convex compact domain whatever so it
will take its its maximum on either on
the boundary so on zero or one
or you can just check it okay if you if
you have a contribution here
okay now if you have a contribution here
okay and f of x contributes well if i
make x larger then the contribution gets
larger
and if f of x contributes negatively
well if i go f down to zero
i make it larger so in either case make
it zero or one on each point x and you
can only make this guy larger
and so
you prove that these are the same
good
and finally i
defined the cut distance by saying
you want to do now you would like to
have invariants under the labeling of
vertices what is the labeling of
vertices in the our continuum
well so this is the vertex x and phi of
x is the labeling
and what would we mean by the labeling
where we want that if this starts off
uniform that phi of x is again uniform
because that would be analog permutation
do that on your uniform distribution on
these great things so we are ceased to
be measure preserving projection
then if this is uniform then this is
uniform
and so now we define the cut distance
between two graphs by saying we take the
cut distance between the step functions
and then i insert all of this so here is
your full
formula
what's the distance between two graphs
okay all this we had done last time
and i had
stated that theorem so you have these
different notions the subcuff
frequencies the distributions we already
know these are equivalent
you have this
you have the microconund free energy and
the theorem says
that
being a cauchy sequence with respect to
this cut matrix equivalent to all of
this yes so is it meaningful to
normalize the cut distance with the
volume of s cross t
so
i don't do that so i divide by 1 over n
squared i mean the dense setting
and um
and it turns out that this cut distance
if you divide by so let me just go back
okay let me just do something
okay so this
this mean
what here did i call it what you mean
cut
all right
okay so this was the minimum
let me write it in a different way over
all partitions
this joint union discharged
the number of edges
okay
so you see in this mean cuts
i divide by n squared not by the size of
the groups
and my cut metric similarly
divides by n squared and not the size of
the groups
okay it's a different notion of a cut
method i mean for the part magic i
define whatever i want this is my
definition
um and in that difference you i mean
it's just the right definition
you could define it differently you
would sort of later get a different
regularity lemma and stuff but
this is the right version to prove all
these equivalences
and the other one is a slightly stronger
version because you divide by something
okay
um good
i hope this one yes
for this space is
it always complete or
only complete or death squad
only for complex for dance clubs
[Music]
so um
so the thing is compact for dense graphs
and it's not even pre-compact for
for smile
if you have extra conditions you can
make it again complete okay but if you
just want all right so anyhow
jennifer might get to that on friday
i'm only discussing that's right it's
complete
you're not getting anything interesting
oh if you do it like that it's complete
if okay
it is complete
but your sub sequence may just converge
to zero
okay yes you're right
i actually was
making my life too complicated
if you divided by something else you
would still maybe be then you could
discuss as it's complete or not and gets
complicated
so this is the theorem and the general i
even mentioned that last time so this
will be the end of my review
um
so the proof idea is
prove that if the cut distance is
smaller than epsilon that the other
properties differ by at most a constant
times epsilon
and it turns out when you actually do it
the constant will be moderate in terms
of
your other constant of the problem so it
will be k squared times the norm of j
typically
in this example you already can see that
this is sort of something like a cut
and then you sum several of them up
there's sort of some k squared of them
up and there's a j so here you already
see that this min cut
on a given on sort of two graphs
both on n vertices
actually if this is smaller equal than
epsilon then this will be smaller than
epsilon times the l1 norm of j or the
infinity norm of j times k squared
and in general you have to do some
rounding to get sort of to the other so
it's just true okay so you have so this
is typically easy to prove
okay the other different direction is
more difficult and often we will require
actually that the k in the previous
theorem is sufficiently large
to give you a good enough approximation
so it will often be exponentially large
in one of epsilon squared which has to
do with the vxmr dilemma we will discuss
later today
so i will now want to give you the proof
in terms of
the subculture frequencies and the cut
method okay and i do this easier
direction first
okay so this now today i will give you a
few proofs
so um
so i have three proofs so and i have
three times half now i've used up a
little bit but so
so how would we try to prove that
well remember that this cut distance was
defined in terms of empirical graphones
so
it makes sense we want to have these
empirical graph up here okay
so
look at this okay and define
this t zero the subgraph frequency
of
a graph on
by this
form
just a form okay you integrate over
x1 up to xk if you have k vertices and
then you put a w for the edges in h and
you put a one minus w for the edges not
in h
and now
i claim this is equal to that and in a
paper i would say by inspection so i'll
inspect that a little
okay so how does the inspection go
well let's look at one of these little
squares okay so if we have here a fixed
graph g
okay here is g
then on these little squares the
function is constant and equal to the
adjacency matrix that's how it was
divided defined so if i integrate over
this square
well
in general so that means all these x i's
i always have to only keep track which
intervals are in
so if i integrate over these k intervals
i get a factor n to the minus k
now i have fixed the intervals so now if
a sum over vertices in your graph
this becomes the adjacency matrix you
have here 1 over n to the k
and now if you remember the definition
of this thing it was just i don't know
i should do that
here you have it that's exactly this
okay
so that we have okay that's step one
so now we have gone from graphs to graph
one so now we want to prove this thing
for difference of graphs
okay so you do that in two steps
first you observe
that
if you
take your graph and replace it by one
where you relabel vertices with measure
preserving transformation that this
doesn't change this object
second you will prove a bound with this
cut norm not the cut metric
for this difference
so assume we had both
well
so this difference
is equal to the difference where you put
the graphs g
which is equal now if i replace here w
by wg phi
this is equal and then i use this bound
so i get this
okay
and now i take the infimum over all phi
then i get this
which was
uh and i forgot the factor k choose 2.
so if i copy down this factor k choose 2
then i have proven
one direction okay so it's a super easy
proof
okay well
it's not a super easy proof because i
have still to do step two and three okay
so how is step two this is again one of
these proofs by inspection
let's inspect it again
okay so if i replace this w by w phi
what does that means
everywhere in here instead of x i i have
phi of x i
this integral is just an expectation
with respect to k independent uniforms
and if x i's are uniform then phi of x
i's are uniform that was your definition
of a measure preserving transformation
so this is still an expectation over ku
independent uniforms
so you get this
okay so this is just how measure
preserving to end so that step is also
easy so the last step is actually only
place that requires some work
okay
so so let's do that slowly okay so we
have
i write this thing we have this this
subgraph sequences of w okay so we write
this out
and now since i don't want to sort of
have these funny things i just define w
i equals this or one minus this so it's
just the product over i smaller than j
of some functions
okay
so now then this is obviously this
so how would we bounce this difference
but iteratively i will first replace w
one two by u one two
then i will have then i will replace w
one three by u one three and so on
so i will have n choose two steps
okay and in each step
i get a difference of the one i'm just
moving
and here i get a product of the ws for
those i haven't moved yet and for the
use i have moved
which is again some function
okay
so in each step i have this
and i have if you want in front those i
haven't moved yet and in the back source
i have moved and for those i haven't
moved i still have a w and for the other
ones i have for you
and if you want a more formal proof it's
a telescoping some difference which is
sort of a more fancy way but i think
this is actually more intuitive
sorry what was you
you was the
yeah
so you had i wanted to compare t 0 of h
and w
and t 0 of h and u
right i want the difference of this here
so the w i j's are these the uijs are u
or one minus u depending on whether this
is the case
okay and now when i want to look at this
difference i can say okay i have to move
all my wi's to uijs
so i have to move the first one the
second one and the third one so i can
write this difference as one where i
have not moved any we have moved one
where i've moved two where i've moved
three and if i subtract them each time
you get sort of this difference
and so you get this difference which is
sort of the step that we where we are
moving the edge i j
and some of them have been moved and
they are already the use which are
either u or one minus q or there's a w's
which are either w or one minus w
okay
so we need to estimate integrals of this
form okay where this is either this
process
but we will not so now let's observe the
following which is super important
okay
these guys will depend on maybe x i or
maybe x j or maybe nicer but they will
not depend on both
because we had to sum over i smaller
than a product of i smaller than j
and this is the term which has the edge
i j all other edges are different edges
so in particular they don't contain the
pair x i x j
so if you think of this as a function so
if you look at this whole integrand and
you look at these as a function of x i
and x j
these guys will only depend on one of
the two okay
so
if we so imagine for a moment when we
estimate that
conditioned on all the x else which are
not equal to i and j
what do we get
well we get a w i that we get these
factors it certainly depends on i and j
you get a product of some of these guys
which depend on i
which i collect in f
you get a product of some of them which
depend on j which is in j
you you get the product of the others
which i throw also into g
and now all of these where u's or one
minus u's or w's or one minus w's
they're all between zero and one
so in other words f and g are functions
with values in zero one which obviously
implicitly depend on all these other
excites which i have fixed but it's a
function of x i and x j
you can factor this dependence out
but i observe that the definition of the
cut norm if i take the absolute value
here and it takes supremum over all
functions f and g i get the cut node
so in other words
the absolute value of this integral is
bounded by this
okay uniformly in the remaining other
variables
so now if i integrate over the other
variables in zero one i just get one
i get n k choose two
terms
so i get that this is bounded by and
each time you have the same bound here
here's the integral of the other
variables this gives one this gift so
this gets set
which was our last step
so that would be maybe one should first
sort of look at that that way okay
so if i look at this object here okay
and i take this difference okay
what you could say if i just want to
look at
when i sort of look at this object right
just bounce this by one
then you get the integral offset
found that since you have thrown in
absolute value you have to throw in
absolute value here so you get the i not
one norm so the lemma so the first step
so the
step three
in the l1 norm is sort of trivial
okay but you want the cut number the one
norm is too strong
so to get the cut norm you have to do
this trick
okay so you really need to do this f and
g trick here
um
to get out the cup
by the way in this case i don't even
need the equivalence because the f's
are all
coming from adjacency matrices so
actually the f and g's are all zero or
one so this is actually the original
definition of the cut metric but now i
have proven for you this bound for
general graph fonts and not just for
step functions
okay so that is one direction
so now what if we want a pound in the
other direction okay
so here's a zero
and the
10 and the 20 are not optimal and
actually that's not what we get but
that's a sort of the nearest nicest
numbers i didn't want to have square
roots of something and in the end see
that the difference is smaller than 19
or 18.5 or something
but i mean they
you get something like that and sort of
from the i will indicate to you why it's
sort of not avoidable from the proof um
so
so maybe you needed to us right anyhow
so
anyhow if we have okay such that the
total variation distance is bounded by
10 over square root of log 2k
then i claim that the cut distance
between your two graphs
can't be much larger
so why is that
well what we will do
is how we reprove that we will look at
this guy
but i will do a triangle inequality
and i will bound
this guy by the difference between g
and
a random graph g k of w of g
then i will take the difference between
two of those and then i will take a
difference of the last one
and in this triangle inequality this guy
actually goes to zero so let's look at
this statement this statement says that
if you choose an inhomogeneous random
graph
generated from microphone
it converges back to the graph
now you may have
some of you may have seen that for gnp
okay if you calculate cuts in g and p
okay
you want cuts between s and t well in
expectation it's just s times t times p
which is p is this random variable
say n squared many random variables so
it's super highly concentrated
exponentially in n squared
there are four to the n many possible s
and t's so it's still highly
concentrated so it's so highly
concentrated that you can actually
converge
this expectation bound to a bound
sort of which goes this yes
all graph fonts i will use eventually
that this and this is the same
and
that is actually why i defined this guys
the way i define to become otherwise
okay i will comment on that on the next
slide
but
okay so it's not how to show the
existence okay so this gnp argument
holds for w random graphs as well
except that now you also have to compare
the matrix w of x i x j
to w itself
and so there's an extra step where this
is can be either proved by some abstract
nonsense for those who you know it's
called
new statistics
and um
but you can also prove it really by hand
it's sort of i gave that as an exercise
in my upper division undergraduates okay
it's easy to prove
nobody complained about that exercise
um and um
it's really easy to prove if i if i give
you the hints how to prove that you can
he can prove it in half an hour because
he's done this stuff a lot and anybody
in the audience can prove it in an hour
and my students need an afternoon
so
so that's easy
however in general
the bound you get the rate of
convergence is just abstract we know
there is some rate of convergence let's
use statistics and in particular it will
depend on w so that will not be good
enough if we want really this
quantitative bound
it would be enough to prove that
convergence of these samples for all k
imply
cut
applies this being a cauchy sequence but
i wouldn't get any explicit bounce if i
want explicit bound i need a little more
and for that
i have the foreign quantity of result on
the expectation okay so it says an
expected in expectation
this object is bounded by 5 over square
root of log 2k
now
this result is
one of the central theorems in this
paper of 50 pages and it relies on two
things
one is when you want to calculate the
cut norm you can again use sampling
so you want to calculate the cut norm
between
let's say you want to compare gk of w
and gk of some other
u prime that means you take sampling
on your w or on a graph and the theorem
said if you too if you want to calculate
the cut you can calculate it in
polynomial time sampling with some so
there's some fp test to calculate that
that wouldn't give you such better bond
okay but it turns out
that you also at some point in this
proof
need to
go to a stochastic block model so your
proof will actually in the technical
details at some point not in this
sampling required to use the stochastic
block so you will have to approximate w
by a stochastic block model and for that
you need the regularity lemma and
luckily you only need the weak
regularity lemma for you give or you
don't get a tower
but you get something like an
exponential which in this version is
inverse function of so you get this
point
okay so i will not prove that to you um
it would probably take half an hour if i
sort of already have proof the semiret
dilemma and if i had the sampling so
anyhow it's
it's true okay
and
so we will use that okay but i argued to
you that it should converge okay now
it's actually easy
so let's look at that okay now this is
just koshy schwartz right right take
this i take this
w
i do the graph sampled from the sgk of
the graph
okay so this is just
i use this as an inhomogeneous random
graph so i have here now my two
inhomogeneous random graphs and i have
this
now i use and now i take expectations
and use the previous bond
so the previous bound said this
expectation was smaller than 5 over
square root of log 2k
uniform in double d so it holds for this
one and for this one so it's just 10
over square root 2 log k
and this one is the expectation of these
two guys
and in principle i have a distribution
here and a distribution here
and i can choose them independently of
each other i could choose it the same i
can choose any coupling okay
so
now if i can choose any coupling okay
so it's still true here okay so what do
i do here this is a number which is
between 0 and 1.
so the expectation is bounded by the
probabilities that it's different from
zero
and now if i use a general coupling
between these two randomness
this is actually nothing but
um
oh i haven't done the coupling yet so
now i claim this why do i claim this
well
i claim this is equal to this
because this guy has the same
distribution as this so why is that
here i choose x1 up to xn
up x1 up to xk uniform at random in zero
one
with probability one over k that will
fall into an interval corresponding to a
given vertex here
so in other words
this
this sampling that i effectively do by
independently choosing x1 up to xk in 0
1
correspond to choosing
v1 up to vk independently in your vertex
set
but that was the definition of sampling
so that answers your question jagane
and it also now tells you
why i did sampling this repetition
because by because this guy for this
continuous variables there makes there's
no way to have not a petition i mean
they don't repeat anyhow but anyhow so
this one translates to that one and not
the one
without this sort of this without
replacement
so this is equal and now this
probability okay if i do a coupling
is bounded by the total variation
distance of the two samples
and which our assumptions of the
lemma said that we assume that this is
bounded by this christian indeed this
assumption is indeed because of your
lemma coming from the other thing right
if
can you click the next one
if this expectation was not of order one
over response script
no no no
right so if you have put your 1 over log
2k then i get here
11. yeah
that's what i'm saying so this is
extension but you are not going to show
us that right expectation so
and this log 2 comes from the summary
which i will show
so
it sort of makes some sense okay why
does it make sense
if you look at a sample from a large
graph g and k vertices
that sample will produce you a graph on
k vertices
okay
so this will actually produce to you for
those of you who know summer ready
partitions it will produce your
semi-ready partition where our
probabilities are either zero or one
okay
so this sampling actually produces a
block model approximation to your graph
morally right so i have this graph i
sample and now i get back another graph
well this graph is sort of some
approximation to my original graph
and there is a theorem which is sort of
uncertainly not going to prove that if
you want
that this is distance between a graph
and its sample is smaller than epsilon
you need e to a constant divided by
epsilon squared there are sort of
counter examples
which will actually
work through the proof i'm going to give
you later and in each step change your
graph in such a way the bounds are
proven will be tight
and prove that the bound i will prove
will be actually
up to constant optimal so you actually
need something like that okay so this is
not an accident you really need you
can't expect to just sample four
vertices from a large graph and get a
good approximation
so you can't expect this to be
polynomial for general graphs
i don't know whether
so you can't expect it and i would
almost think that using the results we
know but similarity partitions you could
actually prove that you can't do it
and yeah you can't
question perhaps this exists okay how
large this case is uh should be in order
to no longer
over k
squared over so it has to be large
enough that this is smaller equal than
one or if you want smaller than one half
otherwise so if it's not smaller than a
half this bound is trivial
and if this is smaller than one half
you'll find and if you want to be one
tenth
then you get sort of so you get sort of
if this should be epsilon you get
something it's exponentially one over
epsilon squared
so that was easy technical question you
can probably explain that to my first
business
um
so
summary so far
graphics are functions of two variables
in some feature space
if you give me a probability
distribution over features i get a
natural
random graph model called inhomogeneous
random graph
uh suviq mentions this morning you can
make us also sparse by taking this graph
and then keeping each edge with
probability
one over n
now suddenly you get the spouse graph so
that is the inhomogeneous random graph
in the sparse regime which was first
studied by ebola janssen and these guys
and then we prove the theorem which uh
suvik mentioned okay and finally if two
graphs are close in the cut metric they
have similar subgraph counts
distribution of sample subgraphs
multi-way cuts and
physics quantities free energies
and you can turn it around and i showed
you how to turn it around
in
in the case of
these two which we have seen i
equivalent
and i hit a little bit from you how to
exactly do it but i also hinted to you
how you could do it essentially if you
only can prove that these
so so what have we seen we have seen
that graphs so now that we have not yet
seen so we have seen that if you take a
graphone
you get a graph
and for any n you can generate one and
we actually have seen that this graph
skips back the graph we have not seen
that in general how we have a sequence
of graphs conversion but we have seen
how the graphs you generate like that
converge back to that
okay and if you just want that for a
given w it converges at some rate you
have no understanding of that easy to
prove and that would already give the
equivalence on the previous side but it
wouldn't give an explicit bound you
could worry that it's a tower of towers
or an inverse log star or who knows what
okay
it's but it's not that bad it's only
exponential
okay
so
now i want to discuss limits okay so i
want to discuss graphene as limits in
the cut metric
and heuristically
it's super easy okay so we already have
seen that any graph can be embedded into
the unit square and now here and i
hinted that but i didn't force that
picture
if now you send n to infinity clearly
goes to that picture
okay
if you look in edit randy graph
it looks like that
and if you squint your eyes a little bit
you don't see it here but this is
actually gray
and it's
the side side of the
projection christian look at the other
side oh there you see it
okay
so it's grave is pixel density
okay
um
now
what does
okay and finally you can take for
example a render from the uni so what is
this object you you have already grown
the graph up to
n vertices you add a new vertices and
then you uniformly again add sort of
edges between vertices which are not yet
connected and you do that over and over
again that generates a dense
random graph it turns the so-called
randomly grown uniform attachment graph
there's an analog of a densely grown
preferential attachment graph
and you get sort of this black and white
pictures and they're clearly converged
to that
okay
now clearly converge
is a question what that means okay so we
need some metric and you might say well
i do the l1 metric well that will not
work very well okay here's a l i run
distance between this and this is one
half at every point
so this will not converge to the
distance will not be zero in the l1
distance
um
and
here it happens to work but in most
cases l1 is not good enough so you might
want to think do some weak convergence
or so but the right notion is the cut
norm
and we already defined that right so we
will say it converges
if
and only if
the step graph one converges to w in
this cut metric where you do the info
over measure preserving transformations
so it turns out that the theorem i
just showed you and for which i proved
to you the first part
the proofs can be easily generalized to
prove this okay so if you have
convergence in this cut metric
well i already bounded this for you
which instead of g i have to graph w
okay so i actually showed to you that
this is smaller equal than this
the same proofs give set okay the proof
in the other way also again you put your
your triangle inequality the same proof
will give it goes the other way around
and these i haven't shown you anyhow but
the proofs you do for those actually
will give this sort of a free
okay so this theorem is sort of nice
okay so you have a limit and all of
these can be expressed in terms of the
limit
okay
so and you can imagine what happens
right you will get here an integral over
w
so you define cuts in terms of w you
don't divide by n you integrate between
v i and v j and v i and v j are subsets
of v and now you get measurable subsets
and you take the minimum and that will
give you this limit
and the statistical physics is a little
bit more complicated and i will not
write it out for you but you can also
write it in terms of the w
so
um questions so far
because now i'm heading towards the
samara dilemma but before i do that i
want to see what whether you have
questions so far
yes
like one can check it and make the cut
more rather than the documentary so that
is actually true in that case in the
cardinal
because if you have measure preserving
transformations
g and phi minus w
okay
that's the same since they're invertible
as w g n
minus w phi
and this is the constant function p so
it stays across the function p if you
don't put the phi
so now you get this
in the car
right and now if you want to prove that
you just take the supremum and then if
you write this down in the cut note this
will be actually
the maximum this will be 1 over n
squared
the maximum overall set s and g subset v
of gn
of
some i in
s j and t
adjacency matrix minus p
this has expectation zero so in
expectation this is zero
these are n squared random variables
which are independent they're super
they're super highly concentrated you
can prove concentration
and so for the random graph i
essentially prove to you that it
converges
and for the random graph all the other
ones are very easy to control too and
see that this is the same
that sort of a quick little exercise to
check that it actually works
okay and for the for the random graph
the statistical physicist
gives what's known as a
revised model for those who know what
statistical physics is so
in the limit you get some variation of
i mean here you just get a minimum
of the energies in expressed in terms of
the graph one
if you want to do the partition function
you also have to worry about entropy
and you will have subtract some entropy
term and then minimize again and it will
work okay i will not
um
do it for you here but you can actually
rewrite all of them in terms of doubling
but sample k from w is the same as
as an inhomogeneous random graph on k
vertices
i see what you're saying i should put a
g here
g you're totally right okay
correct
okay
so this converges to the
inhomogeneous random graph
generated by dabbing
more questions
okay so we have sort of now completed
this picture
okay so we have seen that if you form
convergence in the cut metric you have
sort of a notion of convergence here
it's equivalent in the cut method or in
all the other ones
and
you can choose sort of a random graph
like that
and then i told you that it's easy to
prove it converges back in the cut
metric and since all of them are
equivalent it converges back in terms of
all the other ones
and jennifer will talk a little bit how
to do this cycle for spouse graphs
and if you have
if i give you a small sample or not so
small sample a large sample can i
estimate my w
okay so that's a little preview on what
jennifer will do
um so we have undone all that okay so
now is
[Music]
okay i can say something about that
okay so since there are
since here
you have measure preserving
transformations
it's clear that the limit
okay
so
so w
limit
even only if
delta
w
is a limit and
u is also
even only if this is c
right
because if this is a zero then
then you could put u that would still be
true and if this is non-zero well it
can't converge to both now the question
now is and that also means that
these two will generate the same
energy smarter
right
so that's a question we never asked
before but you could ask
when do two
graphs generate the same random graph
and one way is clearly the case if i
look at w phi
right of x and y
this is w of five x
five five
so if phi is natural percent and even
from one probability space to another
then if this is sort of
if this is distribute right if x is
distributed to mu in some space omega 1
and phi of x is measure preserving from
5 from omega 1 to omega 2 and it's
matter of observing then phi of x is
according to
distribution according to u2 so if there
exists such a thing
then this one will generate the same
random graph right so that is what i was
mentioning before
you could have some measure preserving
transformation from rd this gaussian
into zero one and this would generate
the same
distribution if you just transform your
graph from the column
um
now
if you stay in your original space
that's still true if fire is a measure
of preserving so you might think that
this statement only if let's say now
both u and w
go from zero and square
one
okay you might suspect that this is
different
only and that is actually what people
thought for a long time one of my
colleagues here in stats had the theorem
stating that
but it's not true
it's almost true what is true
is that if you can find a sequence of
user's operation
it actually turns out the sequence only
has to be of next
so
it's clear that if i have right
if
w1 equals u51
and then i have w2 equals mu
by two
the cut distance between this is zero
the cut distance between this is zero
therefore the cut distance between this
and this is zero okay
and that's the theorem
so
w1 and w2
have the same limit can both describe
the limit if and only if there's a third
graph
such you can apply a measure transform
preserving transformation to it and get
w one contamination
that holds in very general measure
spaces you could also put the phi on the
other side
it's also an equivalent characterization
which only holds over an atomless
probability space
has to do i mean all of that has to do
effectively
this effect that if i take this
probability space
this is probability space
there's no measure preserving ejection
between the two of them but you can map
all of them to six purchases
and then if you put the step functions
in and do this right this will produce
the contract samples you need where you
really have to go through that to get to
season things like that
but there's not that doesn't appear to
be a way to think of a best kind of
graph like a minimal
courses
graph to describe
the
those are it's actually okay there's a
notion of a twin free graph one okay so
what are twins
you and i are twins if we see exactly
the same graph
so in other words if w
x and y is equal w of x
c and y for all y
x and z are treats
it's a graph and there is
so if there are twins you could just
collapse the twins
create a smaller probability space and
an equivalent dispersion
and that is sort of the minimum
expansion
okay and once you collect the twins you
can actually prove that you can map that
always
to a union of discrete space and the
continued space
so so there is if you want some natural
stochastic block model part of the graph
one
plus some continuous form and there is
some very precise notion in which it's
minute
then instead of contracting twins when
you contract swins you will get a few
atoms they will give you stochastic
block models
and there's some part which is not
contracted or which sort of just gives
you a quebec intervals and those have to
still be described by continuous
so this i mean to prove all of that
requires quite a bit of measure theory
because you can imagine and this is
effectively if i change things on a set
of measure zeros that generates the same
thing and but now you get countable or
maybe if you do these twins you've
already have uncountably many you i mean
the twins i mean it's sort of
then you need to talk about measure
preserving partitions of probability
space it's sort of it gets sort of
complicated but it you can do it
okay so now let's go
to
uh
another question here so the uniqueness
question is an important question and if
i sort of
thank you for asking this question maybe
i should have put it on the slide but
um
i didn't want to so
this is sort of what we know about
uniqueness now given that i defined this
okay there are two questions okay
before we so i have this equivalence
but if i just had stated this theorem
and you hadn't seen what i did before
you might say
well
any any step function if i make just w
if i make g n just as graph on three
vertices and keep that graph then it
will converge to its own step function
so there clearly exists limits
but it do there exists non-trivial
limits right do they exist graphs on
growing sequences which are not just
taking a
taking a finite graph and just blowing
it up such that it looks i mean i can
always take a vertex divide it into
three put a complete graph on it and
sort of create some trivial but other
non-trivial examples
okay
and then can we get an arbitrary graph
on
as a limit of a sequence of graphs
that's sort of
a little bit more than that
okay
and finally
given a sequence is a subsequence that
converges to a graph
now
the answer to the first two questions i
already gave you
because i
said that my students can prove that in
the cut metrics this converges to w for
every w
so this is not empty and actually i can
get any graph
okay
and now
this one well the answer is also yes
okay
so it turns out that every
sequence has a convergent subsequence
that means in particular every cauchy
sequence converges so for those of you
who think topology that means that the
space of graphon if i identify those
which have cut distance zero
becomes a compact metric space
okay
so
with these two yeses what this shows is
that the space of graphons is the
completion
of the space of finite graphs in the cut
metric if i identify graph fonts which
have zero characteristics
okay so if you want i don't know
g is a set
of graphs
if i take g
and identify things with respect to the
cut metric and
put the completion
then this is just the set of all w
one
again
identifying object as a cut
so this is sort of a really so the
complete graph theory is super nice and
so this will for example this would not
hold
if i allowed weighted graphs or multi
grass because then you could put
arbitrary weights on your edges and then
clearly w would become unbounded
and then clearly you could produce a
sequence which goes to infinity and
doesn't have a limit okay so this shows
you already that if you if you had if
you if you start to have unbounded
graphs which should describe things like
power laws
things will go on somewhere
so now i will spend the rest for you to
actually
discuss the answer to three okay so
there is a weak regular terminal which
says the following given any graph on
and any k
there exists a k times k matrix b
such that w can be approximated by the
step function which is constant of
intervals of length one over k and hat
takes the values of your matrix b
and
so you so put differently
any graph on can be approximated by a
stochastic block mode okay
or you could also read this differently
since converge in this is sort of again
related to the convergence of the random
model generated from that
to the other one
so what does this for example tell you
if i have any graphon and i generate an
innomogen's random graph so we know okay
you have any graph which is exchangeable
you know there must be a graph on
generating it by those hoof
now you use this lemma
so you know that that graph one can be
approximated in the cut metric by a
block graph
okay
and now
since converge and it's near and since
convergence the cut matrix equivalent to
convergence in subgraph counts for
example this tells you that the subgraph
counts
in the stochastic block model will be
similar
to those generated by w so if you only
care about motifs in the learning
language of social scientists
and you are not worried about
approximation by some epsilon there is
no reason to consider a general graph in
the dense setting you can always
approximated by stochastic blocks
and if you have physicists and want to
discuss physics the same is true
okay
so
and if you are common if you are
computer science and want to have sort
of max cut and then cut and things like
that the same is again true okay
so that is that okay
second
why is that true so i claim this means
you can actually cover this set of
graphone by some net
of
block graph fonts and for each epsilon
it's fine why is that
well for each epsilon okay i can choose
a block model which is distance epsilon
over two
and now the block models it's just a
compact space if you fix k
it just okay you can just choose
numbers between zero and one
and you sort of just make them sort of
you take discrete values i don't know
one over k is probably good enough
and then they are sort of smaller than
one over k away so your your epsilon
half became an epsilon so you get an
epsilon net this is what's called
uh sometimes it's called pre-compact or
so-and-so bounded what's the name
essentially bounded
totally bounded so this shows that your
your space is totally bounded that
doesn't give you yet subgraph
convergence
but with some extra work actually you
can get sub graph conversions
okay
so i will want to convince you that this
is true
and
so that i will do on the board
is the five in the numerator the
actual number or is it something else
okay you will see how the five comes i
will first move to something where this
is scaled
and then but i will have to the square
root of two would say there is a block
graph on
it's not necessary
so the way i have defined stochastic
block monitor at the same block size if
you didn't want same block size
then actually i could have your sql
okay
so a partition
of zero one so i have some collection of
subsets
zero one is a disjoint union of these
this is called a partition
okay
and the way we will produce this object
is we will take actually average w over
blocks
so
what is w of p
so that's the average
okay
so that
will be constant
on
y i cos y j
and what will this constant be it will
just be the average of the original
graph
over that block okay so this will be
equal to 1 over
the back measure which i just write as y
i times y j so that's these are
arbitrary sets so this you should write
the back measure but i will use that
notation for the back measure
times the integral over y i cross y j
of the value of x and y
okay
and then there is a lemma
which is actually in exactly of this
form
due to free scan
nine something like that
question mark okay
it's due to freeze and con
it says that
for all epsilon larger than zero
for all graphene's w
metric
like this the partition p
into
at most
one over epsilon squared classes
such that
w minus wp
in the cut norm is smaller equal
than someone
okay now
this is depending on the graph one
i get different partitions
okay
but i never need more that many than
many classes
now
when you when you write this here this
bw
would actually have a partition into
intervals right into adjacent intervals
i hear this lemma only give sets y
so how do i get from sets y to intervals
i apply a measure preserving
transformation
so then these guys actually become
linear intervals of this length because
it's measured preserving
so that and if i apply a measure
preserving transformation that doesn't
change the cut metric so if this was
smaller in the
card norm
after the transformation is still
smaller in the cut metric
okay so
and now
this
4 if you take the logs this would be
sort of right you get log base 2 so you
would get here square root of 2 over log
base 2 of k okay now this actually says
they exist so
what if k is much smaller
where you take your blood model and
artificially divide it into smaller
blocks
and choose for w is the same on it
and this hasn't changed anything
well
i'm cheating a little because on your
smaller sub blocks this would not be the
average anymore so you need to repair
that somehow
so that will cost you some factors
but if you do that and i have sort of a
division into five interval one is this
length one is this length one is this
length
i can subdivide into tiny intervals
now
here's the end of that so
i have a division into three intervals
okay
so this will be my k which is smaller
than
it's three intervals but i don't have
equal legs okay
so they look like that
okay so that will be k smaller than four
to one over epsilon
now i take a very fine partition
okay
and then i place my graph on by the one
that i just claim it lives on this
partition but i don't change it
okay
well
so
it all works out very fine except that
this boundary because i don't know as i
choose this or this so i make an error
here and make an error here and i make
an error here
so the total error i make if these are q
classes will be 2k
over q because you have sort of a square
and you have sort of your errors here
and here right here okay so you make an
error here so you have to make q large
enough to control this error so you want
that to maybe
be epsilon over two
so now i need to have epsilon over two
so suddenly i get here four
and actually in my proof i will need
epsilon over 3
so i actually get 9
so i already get 2 to the 18 over
epsilon squared okay so i will make my
original error epsilon over 3
then do this subdivision into enough
classes that this error is small
and then i have to do some other massage
revolution a little bit more
but this is already 18 okay
and 18 is bigger than 4 squared
so if i don't want to write here 4 point
some some something
i'm forced to put a 5 here
and so you see where this comes about
and sort of
this is not
nobody says this is optimal but anyhow
so we want to prove this letter
okay so i argued for you
i didn't quite control the errors here
but you believe me that this is sort of
just this little rounding error that's a
boundary set
any of you can do that and write it out
and you will get some bound okay
you have this error which you have to
control you have to run this error and
okay so
we have to prove this so how will we
prove this letter
[Music]
we will use
an
some
function
some cost function
which will start
below 1 and will go down all the time
and we know and each time i've come up
with better and better approximations
and this cost function i define it such
a way that it's non-negative
and then eventually it will go down
below zero at which point my algorithm
has finished and will have proof have
produced
a thing so how does that go okay so what
i will do is i have the following
algorithm
i define a partition p0
which is just consist
it's a trivial partition okay
so wp 0
is just the integral of w the constant
function
okay
and i will refine
[Music]
0
p1 and so on
until
distance being w minus wp
okay so this will be my goal i will
construct such a thing that it will
finish latest at some time t
okay
and and and okay
so
and
okay
okay t
goes up at most a factor four in each
step
this is finer and finer addition so you
do finer and finer partitions okay
and each time so how will that go
okay so let's just so let's assume
by contradiction
that
w minus w
p k
i call that k so i really shouldn't call
that okay
pt in the cut norm
is bigger than epsilon okay so my
algorithm hasn't stopped yet
my starting partition is just the
partition into
one set which is a whole interval
this conditions in the cut note
and i claim that the algorithm will
finish
at a time smaller than
one of my episodes
but let's just do it instead of claim
and i don't do any of this so let's
assume this is bigger than epsilon
that means the existing s and t
such that the integer over s plus t
of w minus
pt
and absolute value is bigger than that
right
that's just definition of the cut
so i write that as
the scalar product of the function w
and one s plus t
this is
w minus three
okay so if this is bigger than epsilon
here is the vector w minus w p t
and then if the cut number is bigger
epsilon there must be this vector here
such that the scalar product
is sort of something nonzero
okay
and now morally
i just subtract that from this guy
and i will keep doing it and i produce
things which get nearer and nearer to
zero and eventually will have distance
epsilon that's a geometric picture but
how will it work
okay so this is bigger than epsilon and
now i define
this is too low
so i define
vk plus one
as a common refinement
of
the partition pk
the partition t and t complement
and the partition s and s complement
okay so you have some partition into
groups
okay
let's say i only did this t okay so
somewhere is my set t
that goes up to here
well then i will
sort of
divide here
and this is t complement
so so if i just so i had just in this
case i just have divided one class into
two
okay but if this set is not as well
aligned
if this set would sit here and here and
here
here
then you could sort of in principle you
can get double as many classes but not
more
and if you do it for this guy you could
also get double as many classes so we
know that pk plus one
actually
is smaller equals and four pk okay so
the number of classes goes up by at most
a factor of four
okay
[Music]
and now
let's observe something if i look at the
integral
or s cross t
of w p k
plus 1
well
since this since s and t are sort of
subclasses of this okay this is just the
integral over s cross t
double
okay
so therefore
my
so that is one observation and now let
me just
take my note so that i
do it most efficiently
so now we have epsilon
is smaller than
integral s cross t
w
okay so it was w but now i write w p k
plus one
minus w p k
that was just this assumption right
because i now wrote the w like that
so that's my assumption
okay
by koshi thoughts
this is bounded by the
two norm of one s cos t
and the two norm of this guy
so which is the true norm of w
k plus one
minus w
p k
and this is bounded by one so i get rid
of it
and
so now here okay so now i have
that
epsilon squared
is smaller
than
integral w pk plus 1
minus wpk
squared
which is equal to what
wpk plus 1
threat
minus two integral w
p k
wp can you see down here
uh
w p k plus one
plus wpk
but this one again because we are
refining here you actually
can
replace this by just right this is the
same as w
this is
if you look at this here this is refined
but then i integrate of it so by
effectively average over these blocks
anyhow so this is equal to that so in
other words i have shown
that
we now have
okay so i've shown
that then we have
w as epsilon squared
smaller
than w
k
plus one two norm square
p k plus one
squared minus
w pk
squared
okay
so now i get that
um
wpk plus one
[Music]
is bigger
than
epsilon squared
plus w
k
squared
now i iterate so this is bigger than
can you still see up to here or not
so this is bigger equal
than
k plus 1
times epsilon squared
times plus
w
zero which was just w which i just bound
below from zero
okay
but this guy is a function between zero
and one i average it it's still a
function between zero one so this is
bounded by one
so now i have that one is bigger equal k
plus one epsilon squared
which means that i can choose that
actually i will never have to do the
last step so latest step k
i will have violated this condition
so latest at step k i found a partition
so that the cut norm is smaller than
epsilon
and since in each step i only go up by a
factor of 4
i get this lemma which is not here
anymore so i get that the number of
classes
so so the proof gives
the number of refinements
smaller equal 1 over epsilon squared
and the number of classes
smaller equal 4 to the 1 over epsilon
squared
okay
and note
that this thing is actually polynomial
so if i could do this step
constructively
which we currently can't because i have
to still
look over all s and t but if i could do
this step constructively i would have
given you a polynomial time algorithm
to find an approximation into
exponentially many classes
and frieza and khan actually pushed that
a little further and approximated
this
this step and say i mean morally okay
they didn't quite find exactly the right
smt but they're essentially proved in
each step they had a w and in each step
they subtracted a rank one object
and they went on and on and on
and they eventually approximated
an arbitrary matrix by a rank one over
epsilon squared matrix at the cost of an
error order one over epsilon squared or
maybe it was a different polynomial
so this can actually be made into
something constructive
and it's one of these funny things we
have an object which is exponentially
large but i have sort of a
finite description i mean it's always
polynomial n because you have to write
down your your vectors
but you can write down the so their
theorem eventually says if you have any
matrix with entries in 0 1 you can find
the block mode matrix
and you can write it there is some
effective description which is
polynomial in n and one over epsilon
which gives you this approximation
okay even though the number of
partitions is exponential
so
and the fact that you actually need
exponentially many partitions what
people do they give you a graph so they
give you a graph
and they're iteratively they make it
such that on a large scale
the best thing you can do is this and
then on the next scale they refine it
make it such the best thing you can do
is set and so on
and they show that on each scale you are
forced to sort of do essentially what
i'm doing here in the proof
and they show that you need
e to a constant over epsilon squared
many classes
okay so this bound is actually
optimal if you don't care about the
concept
and with that i think i have given you i
think this is one of the most beautiful
proofs i ever i always was scared of
samurai dilemma and then when i saw this
free scan proof
i thought oh this is one of the most
beautiful proofs i've seen in the world
i mean and it's sort of also almost like
i mean
i don't know did you show one proof
where you had to uh what do you call it
potential function so effectively this
is a potential function right so you
have this potential function you show
that it sort of must go up and up and up
and it's bounded by one so eventually
you're done
because this
this
the proof of the
convergence theorem looks somewhat like
that
the party is a backward margin of
condition on
in this case filtrations are partitions
here you enter to find that step for
multiple conversion you have to go to
infinity that's right but because you
know you're assuming that in every step
just thinking what you're saying yes
so actually i sort of said to you this
implies that this thing is uh
what's the name bounded uh
totally bounded it doesn't quite give
completeness and for to turn that into
completeness what you actually need if
you look at this proof we defined
partitions
so if i had started with some other
partition so you can always say if you
give me a graph on angel partition
i claim that i find i find a refinement
by multiplying the number of classes by
four to the one over epsilon squared
so that is still hot right
because this if you had start if i just
had an additional condition that your p
should be refinement of some original q
well i could just take these guys and
make them also refinements of q at the
cost of having more classes
five factor of the classes in here
so you can prove the same lemma by
saying
they're sort of
so you can choose
let's say if you replace k by
2 to the i or something
i can show the delta cut of w
and wbi
smaller equals and whatever
okay where this is now
on 2 to the i classes
and these are refinements of each other
and then you know that these guys must
actually by multiple conversions
converge back to w
almost surely so that i mean i'm just
hinting at
and that you can use to actually create
subsequences of convergent sequences
to
show that essentially this lemma implies
not only total bondness but actually
comparisons
with that i think i have given you sort
of an a hint of these proofs
if you want your welcome the papers are
both published one of them took four
years to find a referee was able to read
it
so one is in 2008 one is in 2012. it's
just a hundred pages you can read it in
some afternoon
okay so
thank you very much for being so patient
with me
so in the end
you said this this is a
freeze cannon proof is easier for you
because you came from
the original
proof if it's a kind of uh now
refined but not very original but
textable
so
so this is also sometimes called the
weak recognition
so i'm just asking that in the cut norm
it's a close approximation in the
regularity level i will ask that between
each of the classes
it's a good approximation
so effectively you multiply your hours
by
k squared or something like that
in this thing and now you can imagine
how this doesn't work as well anymore
because your your errors blow up at the
same time you do this
and you have to sort of do this more
carefully and if you do it right you
will get actually a so-called tower in
epsilon
um so you get instead of four to one
over epsilon squared you get four over a
tower in one of x one square
so so this becomes
i
i couldn't present it that easily here
because then you have to really sit down
right on in the end of the original
proof is as easy as this but the
original setting was so general or
a little bit stronger but for us we
don't need this is enough
this is actually equivalent to
compactness and the original one gives
you a little more which we don't need
okay come pastor jennifer
okay have a good lunch